best-selling author mitch album is known
for popular thought-provoking books like
tuesdays with maury and the five people
you meet in heaven his new novel is
called the stranger in the lifeboat and
it is very good mitch album joins us now
uh all right so mitch the concept here
is incredible there's a giant uh
conference a party on a boat world
leaders ex-presidents celebrities are
there uh musicians there's an explosion
10 people end up in a lifeboat
another person number 11 arrives and
someone says thank the lord we found you
and that person says i am the lord
and that's the setup yeah that's the
setup and then uh
of course they've been crying out for
help they're out in the middle of the
ocean for two days
all they want is help and then when he
enters the boat and he doesn't look like
they think the lord should look because
he's just an average looking guy they go
no you're not him and then this is like
a parable they all want to be saved and
the lord can't help them until everyone
on the boat believes that's right i
wanted to write a book about uh belief
and help you know we all cry out for
help all the time for friends community
the universe god but when it doesn't
come like a sandwich that we ordered you
know sometimes we don't recognize it and
in my life i've learned that sometimes
help takes a while to come and it's not
in the form that you thought it was but
then you look back on your life you say
you know that was the best thing that
ever happened to me yeah that's helped
but they literally are all into tony's
point point in the same boat the hottie
who's because you've got former
presidents and executives then you have
uh staff of the boat so they're all
there to together trying to survive
asking the lord to answer their prayers
and you said the lord always answers
your prayers but sometimes the answer is
no that's right i hadn't thought of it
like that yeah that's one of the why you
chose that way to tell the story well
because because it's the truth you know
uh sometimes the thing we want might be
in conflict with what somebody else
wants right you know i might answer my
prayer but not there right we know from
from football you know god was on our
side we won what was god against the
other teams right you know uh so i
thought that that was an important line
sometimes you know this is a funny book
because you get to sort of put words in
god's mouth so to speak and that's very
humbling uh but it does give you a
chance to explore some lessons that are
important it's one thing to say we have
faith this is another thing to actually
use it um now you wrote most of this
book while you're in haiti at an
orphanage yeah um that you run right and
the kids there were actually some of the
book's first readers yeah did they give
you any feedback um they said this is
very good mr mitch uh i i couldn't
figure out which one god was you know i
have an orphanage i'm there every month
in haiti and uh wow it was the kids
faith that kind of inspired me i think
the faith of a child is pretty
incredible and our kids who have all
their possessions fit in a 12-inch cubby
and yet they thank god for everything
every night so i wanted to explore that
idea yeah it's so nice to see you mitch
nate we should say that mitch was
telling me earlier that he's actually
seen you in a jock strap that you two go
way back we go way better wow we're very
close in a locker room yeah okay
do you say more you go way better that's
something my family can't say that we've
done we have a detroit connection you
said mitch when god takes someone you
love you shouldn't say why did they take
the person you loved there's a better
question that we should ask well you
know
you you know gail that uh my wife and i
adopted one of our kids chica from our
orphanage she had a brain tumor and
she lived for two years which was almost
two years longer than they told us you
would but having lost her you know i
immediately started yelling at the
universe and happy to do this to us but
as the year has passed you know i've
come to realize that she was a gift we
didn't we didn't lose a child we were
given one and so character uh in the
book asked god you know why did you take
my loved one and he's crying and the god
character says well i know you cry
when you lose someone here on earth but
i can assure you they're not crying
and you know if you believe in heaven if
you believe in something that comes out
so i believe that chica is someplace
better yeah then you can take solace in
that yeah amy
tuesday's with mori right here
best-selling memoir of all time of all
time wow how does that land with you
mitch album uh considering it was and i
just wrote it to pay his medical bills
uh it lands with me as a big surprise
yeah it's a familiar one for me mitch
thank you very much it's a pleasure to
have you my pleasure good to see you
mitch all right the book the stranger in
the lifeboat will be on sale tomorrow we
will be right back